ce jour fera date dans l'histoire le 28
juin 1919 congrès de la paix au château
de versailles
après la défaite des allemands en 1918
les alliés organise la paix c'est le
traité de versailles
il associe de se présenter comme ouvrier
en d'état souvent l'audience et une
audience essentiellement au oui il ya
beaucoup de militaires sur la photo on
ne voit pas du tout sourire du côté dé
versailles et le maire de l'époque henri
simon lance un appel à ses concitoyens
néanmoins les édifices publics seront
pavoisés et illuminer les habitants
suivront certainement cet exemple on
parle quand même de paix victorieuse
comme orient c'est la victoire peut pas
être enfin la victoire appartient à
certains et pas à d'autres
c'est aussi comme si on veut faire appel
ou versailles et de se sentir quelque
peu victorieux je dirais c'est après
tout c'est le maire qui clôt par des
chefs d'état y de nombreuses délégations
diplomatiques sont présentes ce 28 juin
1919 un événement menée par le président
du conseil français georges clemenceau
et le président des états unis woodrow
wilson avec deux visions différentes
globalement il y avait l'idée de rendre
le mans plus
sur par la démocratisation prémaman de
rendre le monde plus sûr pour la
sécurité collective sur six nations et
trois rendement peut-être plus
interdépendants il y avait déjà l'idée
de libre commerce
grâce à lui on à clemenceau qui lui il
croit plutôt à la realpolitik à la
realpolitik veut dire aux rapports de
force dont il estime qu une paix durable
repose vraiment sur la force forcé soit
ziff autres documents conservés par les
archives départementales les remarques
des allemands sur les conditions de la
paix ce qui a été ressenti le plus c'est
un diktat imposé ce caractère très
imposé de traiter le fait que les amants
était totalement exclue tout en concert
et comme un objet et surtout qu'ils
étaient considérés comme moralement un
coupable tout les amortisseurs s'opposer
aux réparations en version donc la somme
qui devait pay s était pas possible de
payer jusqu aux années 90 aurait dû
payer il ya des aspects aussi cette
limitation de l'armée allemande dont
l'armée ne pouvait plus avoir plus que
sur miller mais sera au total plus d'une
cinquantaine de documents sont conservés
aux archives départementales en lien
avec cet événement des pièces achetées
auprès de particuliers